what we want to do in this video is
figure out what the limit
as x approaches 0 of 1 minus cosine of x
over x is equal to and we're going to
assume we know one thing ahead of time
we're going to assume we know that the
limit as x approaches zero of sine of x
over x that this is equal to one and i'm
not going to reprove this in this video
but we have a whole other video
dedicated to proving this famous limit
and we do it using the squeeze or the
sandwich theorem so let's see if we can
work this out
so the first thing we're going to do is
algebraically manipulate this expression
a little bit what i'm going to do is i'm
going to multiply both the numerator and
the denominator
by
1 plus cosine of x
so times the denominator i have to do
the same thing 1 plus cosine of x i'm
not changing the value of the expression
this is just multiplying it by 1. but
what does that do for us well i can
rewrite the whole thing as the limit
as x approaches zero
so one minus cosine of x times one plus
cosine of x well that is just going to
be let me do this in another color
that is going to be
1 squared which is just 1
minus cosine squared of x cosine squared
of x difference of squares and then in
the denominator i am going to have
these
which is just
x
times 1 plus
cosine of x
now what is 1 minus cosine squared of x
well this comes straight out of the
pythagorean identity trig identity this
is the same thing as sine squared of x
so sine
squared of x and so i can rewrite all of
this as being equal to
the limit
as x approaches 0
and let me rewrite this as instead of
sine squared of x that's the same thing
as sine of x times sine of x let me
write it that way sine
x times sine
x so i'll take the first sine of x
so i'll do i'll take this one right over
here and put it over this x
so sine
of x
over x
times the second sine of x let's see
this one
over 1 plus cosine of x
times
sine of x over 1 plus cosine of x all
i've done is i've leveraged a
trigonometric identity and i've done a
little bit of algebraic manipulation
well here the limit of the product of
these two expressions is going to be the
same thing as the product of the limits
so i can rewrite this as being equal to
the
as x approaches 0
of sine
of x over x
times
the limit
as x approaches 0 of sine
of x over 1 plus cosine of x
now we said going into this video that
we're going to assume what we know that
we know what this is we prove it in
other videos what is the limit as x
approaches 0 of sine of x over x well
that is equal to 1.
so this whole limit is just going to be
dependent on whatever this is equal to
well this is pretty straightforward here
as x approaches 0 the numerator is
approaching 0 sine of 0 is 0 the
denominator is approaching cosine of 0
is 1 so the denominator is approaching
2. so this is approaching 0 over 2 or
just 0.
so that's approaching 0
1 times 0 well this is just going to be
equal to zero and we're done using that
fact and a little bit of trig identities
and a little bit of algebraic
manipulation we were able to show that
our original limit the limit as x
approaches zero of one minus cosine of x
over x is equal to zero and i encourage
you to graph it you will see that that
makes sense from a graphical point of
view as well